Men are more likely than women to die prematurely, regardless of background. But when you look at men from lower income and minority groups, their chances of living a long and healthy life are greatly reduced. That's according to numerous studies. But what's behind the statistics? In this episode, we speak with one psychologist about depression, substance use, and how issues like gender roles are affecting men and boys in these vulnerable groups. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is Speaking of Psychology.
无论背景如何，男性都比女性更有可能过早死亡。但当你审视来自较低收入和少数族裔群体的男性时，他们过上长寿且健康生活的几率就会大大降低。这是许多研究得出的结论。但这些统计数据背后的原因是什么呢？在本期节目中，我们采访了一位心理学家，探讨抑郁症、物质使用，以及性别角色等问题是如何影响这些弱势群体中的男性和男孩的。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿（Audrey Hamilton），这里是《心理学话语》（Speaking of Psychology）。
Wisdom Powell is an associate professor of health behavior at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hills Gilling School of Global Public Health. Dr. Powell is also a faculty member at UNC's Limeberger Comprehensive Cancer Center and director of the UNC's Men's Health Research Lab. She is a nationally recognized psychological expert on the health disparities faced by minority boys and men. The term health disparities refers to differences in the availability and quality of care that are often experienced by members of minorities. groups. Powell's research focuses on the intersection of race, masculinity, health beliefs, and behavior, and she has been recognized by the American Psychological Association and the White House for her work. Welcome, Dr. Powell. Thank you for having me. How and why are lower-income black men and boys at a significant disadvantage in this country when it comes to health outcomes
威斯姆·鲍威尔（Wisdom Powell）是北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校吉林斯全球公共卫生学院的健康行为副教授。鲍威尔博士还是北卡罗来纳大学林伯格综合癌症中心的教员，兼北卡罗来纳大学男性健康研究实验室的主任。她是全国公认的心理学专家，专注于少数族裔男孩和男性面临的健康差距问题。“健康差距”一词是指少数族裔成员经常经历的医疗服务可用性和质量上的差异。鲍威尔的研究重点是种族、男子气概、健康信念和行为的交叉点，她的工作得到了美国心理学协会和白宫的表彰。欢迎你，鲍威尔博士。谢谢邀请我来。为什么以及如何让低收入的黑人男性和男孩在这个国家的健康结果处于明显的劣势？
and mental health outcomes? Well, I think it's important to keep in mind that the correlation does exist between low-income status and poor mental health. That's a consistent correlation across a number of longitudinal cross-sectional studies. But that's a simple, single story. I think it's important to sort of unpack that and contextualize it because low-income black men and men of color and boys of color are not predisposed to engaging in riskier behaviors or having poor health outcomes. There are a lot of sort of contextual issues and factors that drive those associated.
以及心理健康结果？嗯，我认为重要的是要记住，低收入状况与不良心理健康之间确实存在相关性。在许多纵向和横向研究中，这是一种一致的相关性。但这只是一个简单、单一的故事。我认为有必要对这一点进行剖析和情境化，因为低收入的黑人男性、有色人种男性以及有色人种男孩并不是天生就倾向于从事更高风险的行为或拥有不良的健康结果。有许多情境问题和因素推动了这些关联。
We know that when people have lower income, they have lower access to resources, they have lower access to opportunities for upward social mobility, they have lower access to health care and mental health care. And because of those sort of essential factors, you see this relationship that manifests as one that suggests that being lower income means that you will automatically have poor health status. I think that in order to get beneath that correlation, you have to look at it. at some of the mechanisms driving it, including poor access to care and also poor access to jobs and other forms of socioeconomic opportunity. Mascular norms, as they're called in psychological research, are sometimes described as the rules of masculinity.
我们知道，当人们收入较低时，他们获得资源的渠道较少，获得向上社会流动机会的渠道较少，获得医疗保健和心理健康服务的渠道也较少。正因为这些基本因素，你会看到这种关系表现为：收入较低意味着你将自动拥有不良的健康状况。我认为，为了探究这种相关性背后的原因，你必须审视导致它的某些机制，包括获得护理的机会较差，以及获得工作和其他形式的社会经济机会的机会较差。在心理学研究中被称为“男子气概规范”的概念，有时被描述为男子气概的规则。
They include specific ways men are told they should act, be tough, stay in control, be a provider, etc. What effect do these norms have on men's mental health over time, particularly when men encounter or difficult times or maybe they don't fit these norms? Yeah, so masculinity norms, for example, can govern the way men seek help. They can govern the kinds of disclosures men make when they are feeling distressed or they are exposed to stressful events. But those norms don't operate in a single way all the time.
它们包括告诉男性应该如何行事的具体方式：坚韧、保持控制、成为顶梁柱等。随着时间的推移，这些规范对男性的心理健康有什么影响，特别是当男性遇到困难时期或者可能不符合这些规范时？是的，例如，男子气概规范会支配男性寻求帮助的方式。当他们感到痛苦或暴露于压力事件中时，它们可以支配男性进行的披露类型。但这些规范并非总是以单一的方式运作。
They vary from moment to moment situation to situation, such that, you know, a man who enact a particular masculinity in the boardroom may enact a very different kind of masculinity on the street corner. It's just, it is more complex than that. But in general, when men adhere rigidly to the kinds of norms that encourage them to not share their emotions to be sort of relentlessly self-reliant without, you know, seeking the help or support of others, they can have poor mental health outcomes, particularly more depressive symptomatology, because doing so cuts them off, I think, from the social networks and the social supports that might help them get through a difficult time. The norms around masculinity also vary by race and social location. So it depends on where you sit
它们时刻在变，因情境而异，比如，一个在董事会中表现出特定男子气概的男性，在街角可能会表现出截然不同的一种男子气概。事情就是这样，它比这更复杂。但总的来说，当男性僵化地遵守那些鼓励他们不分享情感、表现得无情地自力更生而不寻求他人帮助或支持的规范时，他们可能会产生不良的心理健康结果，特别是更多的抑郁症状，因为这样做，我认为他们会把自己从那些可能帮助他们度过难关的社会网络和支持中隔离开来。围绕男子气概的规范也因种族和社会地位而异。所以这取决于你坐在哪里
on the social ladder, how you enact the particular brand of masculinity. Lower income men and men who have been etched out of the opportunity structure may feel a particular pressure to man up in different kinds of ways because they don't have access to all of the ways that a man who's a breadwinner and a provider may be able to enact a masculinity. So you may in those cases see different displays of masculinity. I think it's also important to keep in mind that, you know, among men who are marginalized and oppressed, that often the masculinity that they enact is a response to those threats to their humanity. When people are feeling put upon by social, pressures by
在社会阶梯上，你如何表现出特定品牌的男子气概。低收入男性和被排挤在机会结构之外的男性可能会感到一种特殊的压力，以不同的方式表现得“有男子气概”，因为他们无法获得作为顶梁柱和供养者的男性可能能够表现男子气概的所有途径。因此，在这些情况下，你可能会看到不同形式的男子气概表现。我认为同样重要的是要记住，在被边缘化和受压迫的男性中，他们表现出的男子气概往往是对这些对其人性的威胁的回应。当人们感到受到社会压力、由
exposures like everyday racism, they may act in a particular way because doing so allows them to recoup that part of themselves that gets chipped away at by those social exposures. So it's a very sort of complicated story. I think we're still learning more about
诸如日常种族主义等暴露带来的压迫时，他们可能会以特定的方式行事，因为这样做可以让他们收回因这些社会经历而被侵蚀的那部分自我。所以这是一个非常复杂的故事。我想我们仍在了解更多关于
the physiologic effects of masculinity norms, particularly as it relates to emotion regulation. Okay. And so what do you mean by emotion regulation? Yeah, so when I'm talking about emotion regulation, I'm talking about the strategies individuals use to manage, cope with, sort through the various emotions that come with daily living.
男子气概规范的生理影响，特别是与情绪调节相关的方面。好的，那么你所说的情绪调节是什么意思？是的，当我谈到情绪调节时，我指的是个人用来管理、应对、梳理日常生活带来的各种情绪的策略。
So those strategies can include expressing yourself, something happens to you, then you talk about it, or they can include suppressing those experiences. And what we found from the data is that suppressing emotion in of itself isn't necessarily harmful. It's when you do it habitually. Like if it's your go-to response to all the stress that you experience, that eventually that suppression will cause a rebound in some other areas, like whack-a-mole. You know, you hit it down in one place and it kind of pops up in another.
因此，这些策略可以包括表达自己——发生了一些事情，然后你谈论它，或者它们可以包括压抑这些经历。我们从数据中发现的是，压抑情绪本身并不一定有害。只有当你习惯性地这样做时才是如此。就像如果这是你对所经历的所有压力的首要反应，那么最终这种压抑会在其他一些领域引起反弹，就像打地鼠一样。你知道，你在一个地方把它压下去，它就会在另一个地方冒出来。
And you can see that over time among men who use that as a strategy to cope consistently and habitually. What are some other strategies that men use to cope? I mean, what about anger or withdrawal or just some examples of how. how some of these difficulties can create more difficulties down the road. I think that we are learning more about the variation in emotional responses among men, because quite frankly, we focused a lot of our attention on men's anger. And anger is a legitimate emotion.
随着时间的推移，在那些把这作为持续和习惯性应对策略的男性身上，你可以看到这一点。男性还有哪些其他的应对策略？我的意思是，愤怒或退缩，或者只是一些例子，说明这些困难是如何在未来产生更多困难的。我认为我们正在更多地了解男性情绪反应的变化，因为坦率地说，我们把很多注意力集中在了男性的愤怒上。愤怒是一种合法的情绪。
It's legitimate, especially in the face of social injustice, so I think it's getting a bad rap. But I also think it gets an overwhelming amount. a focus, and despite the fact that men have a range of other kinds of emotions that they experience, including those we call the self-conscious emotions like shame. So I think that when men experience stressful experiences, they respond with the emotion that is closest and most available to them. I think that what we can see in terms of emotions that are associated with more harmful
它是合法的，特别是在面对社会不公的时候，所以我认为它受到了不白之冤。但我也认为它获得了压倒性的关注，尽管男性还会经历一系列其他的情绪，包括我们称之为自我意识情绪的羞耻感。因此，我认为当男性经历压力事件时，他们会用离他们最近、最容易获得的情绪来回应。我认为，就与更有害行为相关的情绪而言
behaviors is that when men experience heightened anger or other negative emotions, they can transfer those emotions into behaviors. So as you were, I think, alluding to, like there are other kinds of things men do in response to stress and negative emotion that can put them on the pathway to poor health outcomes. Like the data suggests that men tend to use more alcohol as opposed to, you know, women when they are stressed. so we can see higher rates of substance abuse in males because of that anger and emotion response. One of the studies that you conducted talks about how men, black men in particular,
我们可以看到，当男性经历高度愤怒或其他负面情绪时，他们可以将这些情绪转化为行为。正如你刚才所暗示的，男性在面对压力和负面情绪时还会做其他一些事情，这些事情可能会让他们走上通往不良健康结果的道路。比如数据表明，当感到压力时，男性往往比女性使用更多的酒精。因此由于这种愤怒和情绪反应，我们可以看到男性中物质滥失效更高。你进行的一项研究谈到了男性，特别是黑人男性，
are very distrustful of the health care system, which I assume can only, like you said, keep them going through this cycle of lack of coping, lack of seeking out resources to help them. You know, why do you think this is and how does this behavior play a role in their health and well-being? I think it's really important. I'm always careful to contextualize these kinds of findings because I think one could look at this and think black men are mistrustful, and that's in some inherent personality flaw or dispositional defect. And actually, mistrust among black men is rooted in experiences in here and now. We know that there's a long, long, dark history of medical malice and apartheid in certain marginalized communities.
对医疗保健系统非常不信任，我猜这只能像你所说的那样，让他们继续陷入缺乏应对、缺乏寻求帮助资源的循环中。你知道，你认为这是为什么，这种行为在他们的健康和福祉中扮演了什么角色？我认为这真的很重要。我总是谨慎地对这些发现进行情境化，因为我认为人们可能会看到这一点并认为黑人男性是不信任的，这是一种内在的人格缺陷或性格缺陷。事实上，黑人男性心中的不信任根植于此时此地的经历。我们知道，在某些边缘化社群中，存在着漫长、漫长、黑暗的医疗残害和隔离历史。
And certainly those experiences are top of mind. for some black men, as they should be. But I think what we're finding more is that even with those experiences in the background, when black men have more patient-centered, empathic experiences with physicians, they report lower medical mistrust. So in other words, mistrust is not immutable. It can be fixed. It can be intervened upon.
当然，这些经历是某些黑人男性脑海中最鲜活的记忆，本该如此。但我认为我们发现更多的是，即使有这些背景经历，当黑人男性与医生有更多以患者为中心、具有同理心的经历时，他们报告的医疗不信任感就会降低。换句话说，不信任并不是一成不变的。它是可以被改变的。它是可以被干预的。
And in fact, we know that mistrust really thickens and thins as a function of cumulative interactions with systems and individuals. And so in the studies that we've conducted, what we've learned is that men who report more frequent everyday racism in their lived experience from day to day have more mistrust of medical organizations. And you can imagine how that might be rational, right? I mean, if you experience discrimination when you're trying to get a cab,
事实上，我们知道不信任感确实会随着与系统和个人累积互动的函数而加深或减弱。因此，在我们进行的研究所了解到的情况是，那些在日常生活中报告更频繁的日常种族主义的男性对医疗机构有更多的不信任。你可以想象这可能是多么合理，对吧？我的意思是，如果你在试图打车时遭遇歧视，
how likely might it be that you would experience discrimination in a situation when you're wearing a backless gown? you're at the most vulnerable position that one can be. So I think that those are rational thoughts, but that to intervene upon them, we have to change the systems and structures that black men interface with so that mistrust will become the natural response. And how do we go about doing that? As psychologists as health care providers, what can the system do to improve on that trust?
你在穿着露背病号服、处于一个人可能处于的最脆弱位置的情况下遭遇歧视的可能性会有多大？所以我认为这些都是合理的想法，但要对它们进行干预，我们必须改变黑人男性与之互动的系统和结构，以便信任能够成为自然的反应。我们该如何着手做到这一点？作为心理学家，作为医疗保健提供者，系统可以做些什么来改善这种信任？
Well, I think that what we, the first thing that we learned in the work that we've conducted it so far is that when men report having a more patient-centered experience that they report lower levels of mistrust. So I think that one clear implication of that finding is that we need to address implicit bias on the parts of physicians, providers, nurses, frontline staff, when they face with black men, when they do come to secure health care. I think the other part of that puzzle is to create more equitable health care. systems that actually focus in on some of the gender role norms that can also push back on mistrust. So if you feel more vulnerable, as we all do in health care transactions, and you
嗯，我认为我们迄今为止在工作中了解到的第一件事是，当男性报告拥有更多以患者为中心的体验时，他们报告的不信任程度较低。因此，我认为这一发现的一个明确启示是，我们需要解决医生、供应商、护士和一线员工在面对黑人男性寻求医疗保健时的内隐偏见。我认为这个谜题的另一部分是建立更加公平的医疗保健系统，这些系统实际上关注某些性别角色规范，这些规范也可以反击不信任。因此，如果你感到更脆弱，就像我们在医疗保健交易中所做的那样，并且你
have these norms that encourage you not to be closer or tell your doctor if you're feeling a particular symptom, then you're going to have more mistrust. But it's all about the context of those exposures and that access to care. We also have a question. I mean, men don't have the kind of socialization experiences with health care systems that women and girls do. I mean, women and girls start interfacing with health care providers in their preteens because of biological changes. Unless a male is playing organized sports, in most cases, he doesn't have a well-boy visit in the same way that girls do. And that interface early in the life course has implications for how comfortable people feel with securing health care or interacting with physicians and doctors and nurses. And so we have to create those opportunities for boys early on.
有这些规范鼓励你不要亲近或告诉你的医生你是否有特定的症状，那么你就会有更多的信任危机。但这一切都关乎这些接触和获得护理的情境。我们还有一个问题。我的意思是，男性没有像女性和女孩那样与医疗保健系统进行社会化的经历。我的意思是，女性和女孩在青春期前就开始因为生理变化而与医疗保健提供者接触。除非男性参加有组织的体育运动，否则在大多数情况下，他不会像女孩那样进行健康的男孩体检。而在生命历程早期的这种接触对人们对获得医疗保健或与内科医生、医生和护士互动感到多么舒适有着影响。因此，我们必须为男孩们尽早创造这些机会。
And that speaks to a need for more policy-level systems change that would encourage and facilitate that early contact with health care systems among boys and men. Another study you conducted looked at the association between everyday racial discrimination and depression among a black man. Based on that study and other research, how do you think racism plays a role in men's health and mental health? And why do some men fare better than others? So there's a long sort of now documented evidentiary base that establishes a link between exposure to racism and poor mental health.
这就说明了对更多政策层面的系统变革的需求，这些变革将鼓励和促进男孩和男性与医疗保健系统的早期接触。你进行的另一项研究探讨了黑人男性日常种族歧视与抑郁之间的关联。基于该研究和其他研究，你认为种族主义在男性健康和心理健康中扮演了什么角色？为什么有些男性比其他人过得更好？因此，现在有一个漫长的、有记录的证据基础，确立了接触种族主义与不良心理健康之间的联系。
It took us a long way to get there to be able to say definitively because now we have longitudinal data to support this causal association that when you experience more discrimination, you're more likely to have depressive symptomatology. And that's perhaps because experiencing discrimination chips away or exact some sort of wear and tear on the spirit that can lead to the experience of more depressive symptomatology. I think it's the frequency of it. It's the chronicity of it. It's also the fact that it's subtle and hidden and difficult to document and therefore verify and get support around. You know, you might experience something very similar and not see that as a racial or racial. racialized experience. And because of that lack of validation, that can also mean that people become more silent about what they experience. They just take it, you know, take it like a man, and they just keep moving forward. I think that the reason we see the differences in men who experience depression as a consequence of racism has to do with a lot of the mechanisms and those things that can
我们花了很长时间才走到这一步，才能明确地这样说，因为现在我们有纵向数据来支持这种因果关联，即当你经历更多歧视时，你更有可能出现抑郁症状。这也许是因为经历歧视会削弱或对精神造成某种磨损，从而导致更多抑郁症状的体验。我认为这是它的频率问题。这是它的慢性化问题。这也是因为它微妙、隐蔽且难以记录，因此难以验证和获得支持。你知道，你可能会经历非常相似的事情，但不认为这是一种种族或种族化。种族化的经历。正是因为缺乏这种认可，这也意味着人们对自己的经历变得更加沉默。他们只是承受着，你知道，像个男子汉一样承受着，然后继续前行。我认为我们看到因种族主义而经历抑郁的男性存在差异的原因，与许多机制以及那些能够
either exacerbate or mitigate those exposures. So I'll tell you a little bit about what we're learning thus far. The data are still unfolding. I mean, this is fairly new work, I think. So what we've learned is that when men are exposed to more frequent racism and they believe that they should shut down their emotions or suppress them as a normative response to stress, they have a more pronounced depressive symptom-symptomatology sort of cascade. So in other words, you know, experiencing discrimination is bad for your mental health, but if you do that and you believe you should take it like a man, take, you know, take discrimination like a man, then you're more likely to have more pronounced depression. And I think that speaks volumes to the need to develop interventions
加剧或减轻这些暴露的因素有关。所以我将向你们介绍一点我们迄今为止学到的东西。数据仍在展开。我的意思是，这相当于是新工作。所以我们了解到的是，当男性暴露于更频繁的种族主义中，并且他们认为自己应该关闭情绪或将其作为对压力的规范性反应进行压制时，他们会有更明显的抑郁症状级联反应。换句话说，你知道，经历歧视对你的心理健康有害，但如果你这样做了并且你认为你应该像个男人一样承受，承受，你知道，像个男人一样承受歧视，那么你更有可能患上更明显的抑郁症。我认为这充分说明了开发干预措施的必要性
that help men to, one, process, addressed, acknowledge the discrimination in their experiences and to give them a broader repertoire of coping possibilities. But, even while we do that, we still need to focus on the structural change. I think all of our interventions for black men who are exposed to discrimination cannot be around helping them to cope better with the discrimination they face. We have to shift the systems, the structures, the places where they live, work, play, pray, and get health care so that those spaces feel humane, warm, and open for them. Well, this has been very interesting, Dr. Powell.
帮助男性：第一，处理、解决、承认他们经历中的歧视，并为他们提供更广泛的应对可能性。但是，在我们这样做的同时，我们仍然需要专注于结构性改革。我认为所有针对遭受歧视的黑人男性的干预措施都不能仅仅围绕帮助他们更好地应对所面临的歧视。我们必须改变系统、结构以及他们生活、工作、玩耍、祈祷和获得医疗保健的地方，以便这些空间对他们来说感到人道、温暖和开放。嗯，这非常有趣，鲍威尔博士。
Thank you so much for joining us. It's my pleasure to be here. I think this is really critical work, and I think we're at a really interesting time in the national discourse around issues that affect boys and men of color in particular, but especially those that affect male health disparities. I think that as we move forward with this work, what's really important for us to keep in mind, that this work is about creating healthier families, communities, and really ultimately a healthier nation. Thanks for listening. To hear more episodes, please go to our website at speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association, Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢你加入我们。很高兴来到这里。我认为这是一项非常关键的工作，而且我认为我们正处于围绕特别影响有色人种男孩和男性的问题、尤其是影响男性健康差距问题的全国话语的一个非常有趣的时期。我认为，在我们推进这项工作的同时，对我们来说非常重要的是要记住，这项工作是为了创造更健康的家庭、社区，并最终创造一个更健康的国家。感谢收听。要收听更多节目，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。代表美国心理学协会，《心理学话语》，我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。